sur le petit balcon de son appartement
elle domine besançon anne vignot a
rejoint la capitale comtoise pour ses
études il y à 40 ans d'abord du droit
puis de la géographie
elle a grandi dans une cité ouvrière
près de dole dans le jura un père
ajusteur mécanicien est mère au foyer
aux ambitions modestes pour ses cinq
enfants
j'avais une maman qui avait en tête que
quand on était ouvrier si on est des
filles et qu'on arrivait déjà être
secrétaire chez solvay
c'était une réussite sociale ma mère a
découvert qu'un jour je rentrais dans un
laboratoire de recherche elle a trouvé
ça surréaliste
puis un jour elle a découvert que je
rentrais en politique j'ai trouvé ça
hyper surréaliste et il m'a dit elle m'a
dit mais mais c'est incroyable ce que tu
es en train de faire et pourquoi tu fais
tout ça et je lui dis mais parce que
parce qu'il ya plein de choses à faire
dans la vie et je veux tout exploré à la
fin de ses études
anne vignot intègre le cnrs comme
cartographes
elle est aujourd'hui ingénieur de
recherche spécialisé en géographie
historique et ça c'est mon fiston
donc oui on a croisé entre vague red
room c'est et damas elle part à
plusieurs reprises en syrie
étudier l'aménagement du territoire à
l'époque gréco-romaine
elle s'intéresse aussi aux tourbières de
franche comté ou aux rivières du massif
jurassien soir en 2005 c'est en tant
qu'ingénieur de recherche pour présenter
un jardin de l'époque néolithique
quelle est pour la première fois invité
sur un plateau de télévision
elle ne se lance en politique que cinq
ans plus tard à l'âge de 50 ans je vous
présente madame alliot qui est donc la
tête de liste europe écologie élue
conseillère régionale en 2010 puis
conseillère municipale et adjointe en
s'est imposé dans cette campagne à la
tête d'une large union de la gauche
on va pas commencer à refaire des débats
qu'on a eu on a les réponses dont on
sait où on va anne vignot elle est dans
une nouvelle génération de femmes qui
arrivent vingt ans après l'obligation de
la parité
je pense que les premières femmes et se
soit imposé un peu comme les hommes
elles avaient un peu les travers des
hommes
aujourd'hui les femmes qui arrivent en
politique elle arrive sur d'autres
façons de faire de la politique qui est
peut-être moins à brut mois moins
violente le fait d'être pour elle à la
fois une femme à la fois d'être
écologiste est à la tête d'une alliance
de gauche
pour moi c'était ma cité la bonne
combinaison makan a réussi à faire cette
alliance là et ça je crois que c'est sa
très grande victoire
pour cécile prud'hommes collaboratrice
d'un de vidéos à la mairie depuis six
ans et patronne régional d'europe
écologie les verts la promotion dan
vigneault tout juste sexagénaire est
jeune en politique relevait de
l'évidence on sais pas dit elle a les
dents qui rayent le parquet saluera bien
le rôle de maire c'est pas ça du tout
mais par contre
on saigne elle a les épaules pour
pouvoir encaisser le choc
20 c'est plus sain et après comme elle
est vraiment pu nas on sait qu elle
lâchera rien une pugnacité désormais en
première ligne à l'épreuve du pouvoir
anne vignot est une des seules
écologistes à la tête d'une grande ville
de france
elle est aussi la première femme à
devenir maire de besançon